LOWER DRUG PRICES.
BUT FIRST, PARADING AG BARR,
BEFRIENDING RIOTERS.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
OVER THE PAST MONTH OR SO, THE
ANGLE HAS BEEN TELLING YOU THAT
THERE IS NO DISTANCE BETWEEN THE
MOB IN PORTLAND AND SEATTLE
TRYING TO BURN DOWN FEDERAL
BUILDINGS AND THE DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL.
AND ONCE AGAIN, THEY HAVE PROVED
OUR POINT.
FOR SEVERAL HOURS TODAY, WE SAW
THE MOBSTERS AT WORK.
BUT THEY WEREN’T OUTSIDE OF THE
BUILDING.
THEY WERE INSIDE VERBALLY,
VICIOUSLY ATTACKING ONE OF THE
MOST WELL RESPECTED LEGAL MINDS
IN AMERICA.
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR.
>> SHAME ON YOU, MR. BARR.
SHAME ON YOU.
>> Q HAVE CONSISTENTLY
UNDERMINED DEMOCRACY, UNDERMINE
THE CONSTITUTION, UNDERMINES THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELL-BEING OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> YOU BROUGHT YOUR TOP STAFF
BUT YOU BROUGHT NO BLACK PEOPLE.
THAT, SIR, IS SYSTEMATIC RACISM.
>> YOUR PEACEFUL PROTESTING IS
ININ A DISGRACE.
>> LET ME JUST TELL YOU.
I’M STARTING TO LOSE MY TEMPER.
>> IT IS MY TIME AND I CONTROL
IT.
>> 10:32 REQUIRES THIS COMMITTEE
WITH THE CONDUCT OF THIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND WHETHER YOU
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
>> Laura: FOR THE RECORD,
AG BARR’S CHARACTER, HIS
REPUTATION, HIS CREDENTIALS
UNIMPEACHABLE BUT I CAN’T SAY
THE SAME FOR THOSE FOLKS.
I CERTAINLY COULDN’T SAY THE
SAME FOR ANY OF THE DEMOCRAT
LOUDMOUTH HURTLING AND INSULTS
AT HIM.
UNLESS YOU HAVE BEEN FORGETTING
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN MAJOR
AMERICAN CITIES, HERE IS A
REMINDER.
[CHANTING]
>> HEADS-UP!
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, HOWEVER,
NEED YOU TO SEE SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT.
>> OF THE PROTESTERS AREN’T
MOCKED.
THEY ARE MOTHERS, VETERANS AND
MAYORS.
>> WE HAVE SEEN MOTHERS AND
VETERANS WHO WERE PEACEFULLY
PROTESTING, NOT THREATENING THE
FEDERAL COURTHOUSE, BEATEN.
>> THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PROTESTERS ARE PEACEFUL.
>> MOST OF THE PROTESTS HAVE
BEEN PEACEFUL, YOU KNOW THAT.
>> Laura: NOW, WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW IN THIS COUNTRY WHAT APPEARS
TO BE A VERY ORGANIZED EFFORT BY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO CREATE CHAOS AND
UNDERMINE OUR FAITH AND RULE OF
LAW.
AND THE DEMOCRATS, YOU WATCHED
THEM TODAY, THEY JUST DO NOT
CARE.
NOW, THEY ARE EITHER WILLFULLY
AND PURPOSELY IGNORING THE
DANGEROUS TO OUR ENTIRE SYSTEM,
OR THEY ARE WILLING TO LET IT
ALL BURN JUST TO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
NOW, BARR HAS SEEN A LOT IN HIS
CAREER COULD HARDLY BELIEVE WHAT
WAS UNFOLDING.
>> A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
REGARDLESS OF YOUR POLITICAL
VIEWS SHOULD CONDEMN VIOLENCE
AGAINST FEDERAL OFFICERS.
I SEE SOME OF THESE
LATIN AMERICAN COUNTRIES AND
CENTRAL AMERICA WHERE THE POLICE
ARE VERY, VERY BRAVE BECAUSE
THE GANGS ARE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH AND GO TO THEIR HOUSE AND
KILL THEIR FAMILIES.
YOU NEVER THINK THAT COULD
HAPPEN HERE, BUT YOU CAN NEVER
THINK SOME OF THE STUFF WE ARE
SEEING TODAY COULD EVER HAPPEN
HERE.
>> Laura: BUT IT IS HAPPENING
AND IT IS HAPPENING BECAUSE
DEMOCRAT MAYORS, GOVERNORS,
SENATORS, AND THOSE CONGRESSMEN
HAVE MADE A CONCERTED DECISION
TO SIDE WITH THE VERY RADICALS
WHO ARE THREATENING THE LIVES OF
INNOCENT AMERICANS.
THEY ARE DOING IT ON INTERSTATE
FREEWAYS, BRIDGES, AND FEDERAL
BUILDINGS, AND FRANKLY, ANYWHERE
WHERE RIOTERS GATHER.
>> SINCE WHEN IS IT OKAY TO TRY
TO BURN DOWN A FEDERAL COURT?
IF SOMEONE WENT DOWN TO THE
STREET TO THE COURT HERE, THAT
BEAUTIFUL COURTHOUSE WE HAVE
RIGHT AT THE BOTTOM OF THE HILL
AND STARTED BREAKING WINDOWS AND
FIRING INDUSTRIAL GRADE
FIREWORKS TO START A FIRE, THROW
KEROSENE BALLOONS IN THEM AND
START FIRES IN THE COURT, IS
THAT OKAY?
IS THAT OKAY NOW?
NO, THE U.S. MARSHALS HAVE A
DUTY TO STOP THAT AND DEFEND THE
COURTHOUSE.
AND THAT IS WHAT WE ARE DOING IN
PORTLAND.
>> Laura: MAKE NO MISTAKE,
THIS IS NO LONGER THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY OF BILL CLINTON.
IT’S NOT EVEN THE PARTY OF
BARACK OBAMA.
THIS IS THE PARTY OF ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, ILHAN OMAR,
PRESLEY, THE SQUAD APPEAR THIS
IS THE PARTY OF ANTIFA.
THIS IS THE PARTY OF RADICAL
ANARCHIST AND REVOLUTIONARY WHO
COMMIT ANY CRIME AGAINST ANY
PERSON OR ANY PIECE OF PROPERTY
IN ORDER TO GET THEIR WAY.
AND WHAT IS STUNNING TO WATCH IS
THAT THESE DOMESTIC TERRORISTS
HAVE BECOME IN THEIR OWN WAY AND
ACTIVE FEATURE OF THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN.
WE HAVE TO KEEP UP THE CHAOS TO
PROVOKE A REACTION FROM FEDERAL
LAW OFFICERS TO AFFECT THE
OUTCOME OF A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
AND JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
DEMOCRATS ARE TAKING CUES FROM
THESE DESPICABLE PEOPLE,
PERFORMING FOR A TELEVISION
AUDIENCE, ATTEMPTING TO CARRY
OUT WHAT WAS EQUIVALENT OF
REPUTATIONAL FASCINATION OF
BILL BARR.
>> HAVE YOU NOW HOLD FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO STOP USING
THESE CHEMICAL IRRITANTS ON
PROTESTERS?
YES OR NO?
>> PEPPER SPRAY QUESTION TO
MIKE?
NO.
I THINK IT IS A NONLETHAL
OPTION.
>> FOR PROTESTERS?
>> KNOW FOR RIOTERS.
>> THAT WAS MY QUESTION FOR
PROTESTERS?
NO, FOR WRITERS.
>> CIRCUM- AMERICA WAS FOUNDED
ON THE FREEDOM.
>> YOU ARE CLAIMING MY TIME, I’M
SURPRISED THAT YOUR LACK OF
RESPECT FOR A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
>> Laura: I LAUGHED OUT LOUD
IN MY KITCHEN WHEN I SAW THAT
TODAY.
THE GENERAL LADY WAS TREATED
WITH MORE DEFERENCE IN THAT
EXCHANGE THEN SHE DESERVED.
SHE TOOK HER 5 MINUTES TO LAUNCH
A PERSONAL ATTACK ON A MAN WITH
AN IMPECCABLE RECORD.
LIKE HER COLLEAGUES, SHE
DISASSEMBLED, DISTORTED, AND
DEMONIZED FOR PURELY POLITICAL
REASONS.
HER LITTLE CHARADE FOR THE
CAMERAS IS AN EXAMPLE OF
MISCONDUCT THAT IS BOORISH AND
RUDE, BUT IT IS AN INSULT TO
THE INTEGRITY AND THE HISTORY OF
THE ENTIRE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO SAY TO
MY CONSTITUENTS WHEN THEY ASK ME
IF THE GOVERNMENT HAS DONE
EVERYTHING IN ITS POWER TO
PROTECT THEIR LOVED ONES FROM
DYING?
>> I WOULD TELL THEM THAT
MANAGING THIS KIND OF THING
REQUIRES A LOT OF DIFFICULT
CHOICES, MEANING DIFFERENT
CONSEQUENCES.
>> I’M NOT GOING ALLOW THIS.
>> PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WORKING
TOGETHER ARE LETTING AMERICANS
DIE NEEDLESSLY BECAUSE OF
POLITICAL.
>> IS IT PERMISSIBLE FOR A
MEMBER OF THAT COMMITTEE TO
ACCUSE HIM OF MURDER BECAUSE
THAT IS JUST WHAT WE HEARD.
MR. CHAIRMAN, TO SAY WHATEVER
THEY WANT.
>> Laura: RULES OF DECORUM.
THOSE ARE UNFORTUNATELY OUT THE
WINDOW A LONG TIME AGO AND AFTER
ALL THE PREENING AND STRUTTING
AND OVERCHARGE DEMOTING, THE
DEMOCRATS THOUGHT TO DEPRIVE --
DEPRIVE BARR ONE BRIEF MOMENT OF
HUMANITY.
>> I HAVE TWO CHILDREN WHO ARE
CANCER SURVIVORS SO I FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT THIS ISSUE AS A
MATTER OF POLICY.
AND I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT HAS
MADE CLEAR THAT HE WILL ENSURE
THAT --
>> PLEASE ANSWER MY QUESTION.
WILL YOU STOP PLAYING POLITICS
WITH AMERICANS HEALTH CARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC?
>> Laura: EVERYONE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND WHERE WE ARE.
AS MOB VIOLENCE CONSUMES THE
COUNTRY, WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS COVID CRISIS, DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL PREFER TO BURY THE
CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL
IN THE COUNTRY AND FLOAT
FAR LEFT CONSPIRACY THEORIES
RATHER THAN WORKING WITH HIM TO
RESTORE ORDER AND MAYBE JUST
GIVE PEOPLE A LITTLE.
AND WHY ARE DEMOCRATS DOING
THIS?
WHY WAS THERE NOT A SINGLE
REASON QUESTION FROM EVEN ONE
OF THEM TODAY.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT AOC IN
THE SQUAD WILL DESTROY THEM IF
THEY DEVIATE FROM THE FAR LEFT
PLAYBOOK FOR JUST A MILLISECOND.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE MORE TERRIFIED
OF ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ PLUS
THREE BECAUSE THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT HER ENDORSING A PRIMARY
CHALLENGER.
THEY ARE WORRIED MORE ABOUT THAT
THAN WHAT ANY REASONABLE
AMERICAN THINKS.
EVER SINCE THE IMPEACHMENT
EFFORT FAILED, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE JUMPED ON ONE CRAZY THEORY
AFTER ANOTHER.
BARR IS A THOUGHTFUL AND
DEDICATED CIVIL SERVANT.
HE CAME OUT OF RETIREMENT, NOT
BECAUSE HE WANTED SOMETHING ON
HIS RESUME BECAUSE HE’S ALREADY
DONE SOMETHING.
HE DID IT BECAUSE HE HAS A
PROFOUND SENSE OF DUTY TO THIS
COUNTRY.
HE AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE BETTER.
AND DON’T IMAGINE THAT BIDEN
WILL STOP THE LAWLESSNESS IN OUR
CITIES, BY THE WAY.
>> I WOULD BE USING LOCAL POLICE
AS WE DID WHEN WE WERE IN
OFFICE, WHEN THERE WERE RIOTS
AND FEDERAL PROPERTY AT STAKE,
WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THAT.
WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF,
OBVIOUSLY, THE USE OF LOCAL
POLICE.
>> Laura: OH, REALLY?
[LAUGHTER]
HERE IS WHAT OBAMA AND BIDEN
ACCOMPLISHED IN BALTIMORE.
[CHANTING]
THEY DID NOTHING EXCEPT LET
BALTIMORE AND ST. LOUIS,
FERGUSON BURN!
IN ELECTING BIDEN, THEY WILL
MAKE SCENES LIKE THESE PLAY OUT
IN A NEIGHBORHOOD NEAR YOU.
AND IF YOU’RE LOOKING COME I
DON’T KNOW FOR SOME COMFORT,
MODERATION FOR SANITY?
BIDEN ONLY OFFERS AN INSURANCE
TO THE FAR LEFT AND THE AOC WING
OF THIS PARTY.
>> IF I’M ELECTED, I WILL BE
GOOD TO GO DOWN AS ONE OF THE
MOST PROGRESSIVE PRESIDENTS IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> Laura: HOW IS THAT?
YOU WILL BE GOOD TO GO DOWN AS
THE MOST MANIPULATIVE AND
PASSIVE PRESIDENTS HIT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
MY GOODNESS.
THINK OF BILL BARR WHAT HE HAD
TO ENDURE TODAY AND THEN THINK